It's just a convenient and precise way of describing this string.
Once again, when we're
working with the query model, we aren't worrying about how
to implement these query gates.
That's the same issue
we had with query gates for Boolean circuit.
It's not our job to prepare the input, we're given the input in the
form of these query gates.
I will point out though, that if we know how to
implement the function f using a Boolean circuit, then it is possible to
translate that implementation
pretty directly to a quantum
circuit implementation of Uf, and we'll see exactly how
that works in the next lesson.
As an aside, it is quite straightforward to create a Boolean circuit
that operates like this, using a single classical
query gate for the function f,
but that is quite different from having a quantum
circuit implementation of this unitary gate.
The point, however, is that
for classical query algorithms, having a query gate that works like this is, in fact, equivalent
to having an ordinary
classical query gate for f, in the sense that either one can be implemented using the other.
In this section of the lesson, we'll discuss Deutsch's algorithm, which is a very simple
quantum query algorithm, but it really is a gem.
This algorithm comes from a 1985 paper written by David Deutsch, was one of the very first people to work on the theoretical
foundations of quantum computing.
The algorithm itself represents a very small part
of Deutsch's 1985 paper, and in fact,
the algorithm we now
call Deutsch's algorithm is actually an improved version of the algorithm that Deutsch described.
It provides a very modest example of how quantum computers can
offer computational advantages, but you have to start somewhere,
and it really was an important spark that got things started.
Deutsch's algorithm solves a query problem that's often called Deutsch's problem in the context of quantum computing,
but in fact, it's none other
than the parity problem for functions from one bit to one bit, which we've already talked about.
As we've already seen, there are four functions
from one bit to one bit, and they're described here on the screen by their tables of values.
The first and last of these
functions are constant, while the middle two are balanced in the sense that the two
possible output values
appear the same number of times.
For the two constant functions,
we see that the parity, or in other words, the eXclusive OR of the two outputs is 0,
and for the two balance functions, the parity of the outputs is 1.
So an equivalent way to
describe the parity problem in this particular case, where the function f takes
a single bit as input,
or in other words, Deutsch's problem, is like you see here.
The input is a function f
from one bit to one bit, and the output is 0 if f is constant
and 1 if f is balanced.
As I've already suggested, every classical query algorithm
that solves this problem must make at least two queries to f.
If you learn just one of
the two output values of f, you still have no information at all about the parity of the two outputs.
And this, by the way, is true
even for classical algorithms that make use of randomness.
Randomness can sometimes be very useful for solving query problems, and we'll see an example
a bit later in the lesson,
but randomness doesn't help here.
So our algorithm from before is optimal among classical query algorithms
for Deutsch's problem.
Now we'll take a look
at Deutsche's algorithm, which is a quantum query algorithm that solves Deutsch's
problem using a single query.
And here is the algorithm
described as a quantum circuit.
We have two qubits
initialized like you see here, with the top one initialized to cat 0 and the bottom one initialized to cat 1,
and we'll see why we initialize these qubits like this shortly.
We perform Hadamard
gates on the two qubits, feed them into the query gate, perform another Hadamard
gate on the top qubit,
and then measure it. And the claim is that
the measurement outcome gives us, with certainty, the
correct answer to the problem.
So let's analyze the
circuit one step at a time to see exactly how it works.
The state of the two qubits after the first layer of Hadamard gates is the tensor product of
the minus and plus states.
The Hadamard on top maps
the 0 state to a plus state, and the Hadamard on the bottom maps the 1 state to a minus state.
The top qubit is on the right, and the bottom qubit is on the left, so this is the state that we get.
It's very important that the bottom qubit is in a minus state, by the way, this wouldn't work if we
initialize the bottom qubit
to a 0 state instead of a 1 state.
We're going to expand this state
halfway, like you see here.
The reason for doing that
isn't clear at this point, but it will be convenient
in just a moment.
Next, let's think about
the state of the two qubits after the query gate is performed.
The way the query gate
works is that it computes F on the standard basis
state of the top qubit and XOR is the value
onto the bottom qubit,